ماذا تفعل عندما لا يستطيع منزلك أن
يحميك من الرياح الشديدة عندما
لا تستطيع تدفئة البرد بعيدًا عن
خدود أطفالك أو أيديهم المتجمدة أو
عندما ينهار الثلج ، الملجأ الوحيد
الذي
ألقيت نظرة عليه في كل هذا يقول فاطيم هل يمكن لأي شخص
أن يرحم  لا تحضر لنا طعامًا أو ماءًا
فقط إلى المنزل
، ملابس ابنها ملقاة على
الأرض المغمورة بالمياه
، والأطفال ليس لديهم أحذية مناسبة ، فالأطفال
المحظوظون الذين يركضون حولهم
بأحذية مطاطية يرتدون النعال
، وبعضهم لا يرتدونها على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
هذا الشتاء هو من بين أقسى الشتاء التي تضرب
سوريا منذ عقود ، وبالنسبة لأولئك الذين يعيشون في
المخيمات ، فإنه لا
يطاق الأطفال يبكون من البرد ، لقد
جمعنا كل شيء هناك لحرقه
حتى من القمامة
من البلاستيك إلى الخشب إلى أي شيء آخر
ولكنه ليس آمنًا.
احترق إدريس عندما استخدم والديه
العجينة المتبقية من
عصر الزيتون للحصول على الزيت ،
ولا أعرف ما حدث بالضبط
لكن الموقد انفجر يقول والده إن
الجلد ذاب كما لو كنت قد سكبت حامضًا عليه
يحترق.  تشيع هيئات المحلفين الناتجة عن الظروف المعيشية غير الآمنة في
جميع أنحاء
هذه المعسكرات خاصة في فصل
الشتاء والطقس لا يؤدي فقط إلى تفاقم
الظروف المعيشية الخطرة بالفعل
وفقًا لمنظمة الصحة العالمية ، حيث
يؤدي عدم القدرة على البقاء
دافئًا إلى زيادة
أمراض الجهاز التنفسي الحادة بين الأطفال
وخاصة الصغار.
يحاول الدكتور عبد الرحمن شوفان خنق
صرخات هذا الطفل ، لكن عندما يهدأ أخيرًا ،
يمكنك سماع مدى صعوبة أنفاسه
[موسيقى]
ما قاله ذلك هذا ما كنا
نتحدث عنه يقول الدكتور شوفان أن
الأطفال الصغار المصابين بحساسية القصبات الهوائية
والتهاب القصيبات  يمكن أن يكون الأمر مميتًا لأن
المستشفيات لا تملك الدعم أو
الأدوية التي تحتاجها ، ولا تملك وكالات الإغاثة
التمويل الذي تحتاجه ، وبينما
توجد جهود محلية على الأرض
للمساعدة ، لا يكفي
أن المجتمع الدولي لم
يوقف القتل الجماعي للمدنيين السوريين.
هل ستساعدهم الآن على البقاء على قيد الحياة في فصل الشتاء
Arewa damon sienan istanbul